bonjour jean guilhem darré bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france est ce que les entreprises
peuvent jouer le jeu de ce télé travail
selon vous
toutes les entreprises ne peuvent pas
jouer le jeu ça dépend de la taille en
fait de l'entreprise pour les tpe c'est
vrai que c'est très difficile à mettre
en place on peut rencontrer des
difficultés avec des salariés qui ne
veulent pas être en télétravail on peut
aussi rencontrer des difficultés avec
des salariés qui n'ont pas
nécessairement chez eux un environnement
de travail qui leur permet de
télétravail et le télétravail c'est pas
uniquement rester chez soi et travailler
il ya aussi des notions de management il
ya aussi des notions
d'organisation et ça pour une tpe c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à mettre en
oeuvre que pour une pme ou pour une fois
d'entreprises et pourtant elle était peu
sont soumises aux mêmes règles et donc
risque aussi d amende comme d'habitude
malheureusement n'y a pas de
différenciation qui est faite entre les
tpe et les entreprises de plus grande
taille qui soulève de grandes
difficultés dans de nombreux domaines en
effet l'un des problèmes principaux
c'est ce sont les conséquences puisque
avec 1000 euros par salarié d'amande
potentiel jusqu'à 50000 euros c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas mis
admissibles me supportable
et pourtant et pourtant le conseil
d'état le 19 octobre 2020 a rappelé que
les protocoles sanitaires n'ont qu'une
valeur de recommandation dans les faits
donc l'inspection du travail ne peut pas
imposer des amendes dans le secteur
privé
alors ça c'est un élément juridique sur
lequel on que l'on peut discuter mais il
n'en reste pas moins que sur le terrain
l'appréciation qui est fait par les
chefs d'entreprise qu'ils soient je
m'organise pour que les salariés
puissent être en télétravail soit je
risque une amende de 1000 euros sachant
que au départ on avait prévu de pouvoir
organiser sur une totalité des effectifs
et puis voilà on a changé de cap entre
temps et on arrive le 3 janvier on
arrive dans l'entreprise il faut déjà
changer les modalités puisque là c'est
chaque salarié qui devra être en
télétravail au moins trois jours voire
quatre jours par semaine et ont plus il
ya le problème de l'absentéisme
j'imagine pour les tpe qui est qui
pèsent lourd
enfin vous l'avez présenté dans portal
juste avant c'est une vraie usine à gaz
on ne comprend rien vacciner pas
vaccinés 7 jours 10 jours c'est
extrêmement compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
c'est très difficile de le comprendre
vous avez vous avez développé ça pendant
quasiment deux minutes pour qu'on arrive
à comprendre quelque chose donc c'est en
terre en termes d' absentéisme
il ya effectivement un risque lié le
lion vraiment mikron mais maintenant en
termes de carrière d'organisation de
l'entreprise c'est encore plus compliqué
du fait des différentes réglementations
qui se met en place il ya des problèmes
aussi pour mettre en place télétravail
où est la frontière entre on ne peut pas
à télétravailler il faut qu'on soit sûr
si tu es et l inverse est ce que la
frontière est assez clair selon vous
c'est exactement la bonne question
puisqu'il en fait le d'après ce qui est
prévu en fait c'est que le télétravail
devra être mis en oeuvre quand c'est
possible quand c'est possible mais c'est
une c'est une dans l'appréciation qui
peut qui peut varier il faut savoir que
selon les accords nationaux
il doit y avoir un accord entre le chef
d'entreprise et le seul arrive pour que
le télétravail soit mis en place qui
n'est pas nécessairement évident à
mettre en oeuvre parce que si le salarié
ne veut pas à lui est rentré en
télétravail c'est l'entreprise qui
risque une amende et comment ça se passe
dans ces cas là exactement oui c'est
l'entreprise qui risque une amende
puisque le salarié de l'employeur pardon
est tenu à une obligation de santé
sécurité au travail donc dans l'absolu
le chef d'entreprise devrait imposer du
télétravail ce qui dans la pratique
n'est pas possible en réalité vous ayez
des des contrôles de l'inspection du
travail est ce qu'il y en a eu à
l'époque où le télétravail et est
fortement recommandée alors fortement
recommandée donc on n'a pas eu de cas de
remontée en tout cas en ce qui concerne
du télétravail dans les tpe mais là il
ya une crainte important de la part des
responsables de tpe
tout le contrôler effectivement de
l'inspection du travail et des aides
pour justement favoriser c'est lé
travail ça implique aussi des frais pour
les gens qui sont à la maison 5 défaites
pour les gens qui sont à la maison c'est
implique aussi une potentielle baisse de
productivité potentielle baisse du
chiffre d'affaires pour une visite
surprise aussi très compliqué
il faut aussi dans ce cadre-là avoir une
pensée pour nos collègues qui reste sur
le terrain je pense notamment aux
restaurateurs ou cacher
ceux d'équipement de la personne à ceux
de l'esthétique qui vont voir baisser le
nombre de clients du fait de la mise en
place d'un télétravail obligatoire les
ailes bien sûr qu'il en vaut
le gouvernement et les chefs
d'entreprise les responsables de tpe
sont d'accord sur un point c'est que
l'objectif c'est de continuer l'activité
maintenant continuer l'activité dans des
conditions qui font que on en rencontre
des problèmes au niveau du chiffre
d'affaires et aux niveaux d'activité
elle même ça c'est pas possible et
nécessaire de mettre en place différents
éléments nous on propose la remise en
place naturellement du fonds de
solidarité on propose aussi une
prolongation des délais de paiement cds
concernant
la remise en place des éléments
concernant la le paiement des charges
sociales enfin il ya tout
tout un ensemble de mesures à remettre
en place de façon à ce que les
entreprises notamment les tpe et la
possibilité se sortir de cette nouvelle
bague la passion du mieux aussi
merci beaucoup jean-guilhem darré
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions sur arte france